bring the bar to you tour how's it going
so far it's going incredible I love
playing in Canada period um we got up
here for the first time in 2012 got to
open for like Jason Aldina up here open
for FGL up here
um and I want to say it was like 2018
when we got the headline up here for the
first time and so had plans to come back
in 2020 which I know a lot of people had
a lot of plans but uh yeah it's good to
be back we started in Vancouver and kind
of just been working our way East and
tonight is one that I'm jacked about
like I've gotten to play the the amp
quite a few times but I've always wanted
to play the Scotiabank so I'm extremely
excited you know every night you perform
does it feel like a bit of a party it
does for sure yeah it definitely does I
mean and the openers too we have out
here with us Cameron Marlo and Jordan
Davis it's just
it's just exciting from the moment you
walk in the door until you leave we just
want to make sure that we're leaving
everybody with a smile that's our
mission so okay so you were
you were first performed here
I think so okay okay so from 2012 to now
are you living the dream you're
performing in front of thousands it
looks a lot different today than it did
back then that's for damn sure I don't
think we had one hit back then in 2012
so now come out here and play you know
18 to 20 some odd number ones it's it's
really cool to see kind of the following
that we've been able to kind of produce
up in Canada and and uh just watching
people light up singing these songs it's
I really am living the dream for sure
and you have your own little party back
at home with your four kids yeah that's
a whole different part that's a whole
other kind of party that's a lit that's
a different kind of lip you know what
I'm saying so okay what is the different
kind of energy you need to use with your
party at home versus your party here on
stage
you know I feel like right when you walk
through the door it's go time until nine
o'clock true here is kind of like wake
up when you feel like it work out also
it's a bit of a break no it's definitely
I told you that road trip we took from
Manitoba to Ontario that was by choice I
seriously talked to my wife I was like
when is the last time you could say you
got to do whatever you wanted to do for
24 hours that's true and so 14 hours in
it was really cool in the last 14 hours
I was like freaking out yeah I was like
get me off get me off this thing
um but gosh I miss them this is the
longest I've ever been away from my wife
and my kids so 10 days is kind of our
our maximum if you will so after our
show in uh Ottawa we'll fly back home
and okay go ahead and get that get the
ringing night so do you do a lot of
FaceTime how do you stay connected
FaceTime yeah it's the most incredible
invention I know what did we do before
that
I mean seriously I don't remember but uh
yeah I I think I annoy my kids how many
times I just want to see their faces
yeah you know so but it kind of it kind
of makes the road feel like home you
know being able to FaceTime them and
see what they're doing at school and
what they did that day and all that kind
of mess but I miss them miss them bad so
I loved your post on Valentine's day
you'll learn in all your photos and then
your song Angels don't always have wings
why was that the right song to use to
you know showcase Your Love With Lauren
yeah I mean it's not out of the ordinary
you know for me to to uh
put a love song out there but but this
one's a lot different to me I feel like
every every time I'm writing for a
record my my new mission is finding a
new way to say I love you right and we
just celebrated uh 10 years of marriage
in October
um and this lifestyle is just nuts I
mean it truly is and and for someone to
I don't know just deal with it all you
know for for 10 years and and be my rock
be that person that I've always just
leaned on and and still to this day
we're more in love than I've ever been
like it's it truly the song is is kind
of an apology for like dealing with my
crap for the last 10 years but it's it's
mostly a thank you you know what I'm
saying
um because this is not this is not the
easiest thing in the world and and the
way that she has done this with me with
so much grace and with our kids too has
just been uh it truly is like part Angel
part human like it's not a joke
you mean it yeah for sure now I know
that you and
Katy Perry have bonded over being
parents for sure uh your kids are picky
eaters
um hers is a more picky eater than mine
I've got a couple picky eaters like the
typical we don't want broccoli you know
like that whole thing yeah yeah I mean I
would say the the minimal time that me
and Katie got to spend together working
on the music video and doing the CMAs I
mean literally the entire conversation
was how we how we parent so that's how
you know you've got that you're over 30.
it's true have you planned any play
dates or have you had any play dates
with your kids in Katy Perry's kid Daisy
we have not
um it works I don't get out to LA very
often and she doesn't get to Nashville
very often but I would imagine the next
time
it is that that'll definitely happen we
should make this happen I just want to
see the photos uh why was she the
perfect person to collaborate with on
your song where we started you know I
didn't know that she was a perfect
person until she was yeah I mean I
literally that song was never meant to
be a feature period I wrote that song
with a buddy of my name John Bellion who
was one of my favorite pop artists and
favorite pop writers and and towards the
end of the record cycle there was a
um a girl named Allison Jones that works
at our record label and she was like we
should do a feature on this song I was
like well who do you who do you have in
mind and she was like I'm thinking Katy
Perry it's like are you serious you know
like not in a but in a way of like she
doesn't know who I am like she's never
going to respond to this and like I
guess the song spoke to her and she
responded like literally the day after
and uh that's when we started kind of
FaceTiming and talking through what
parts we were going to do and where I
was going to sing harmony where she was
going to sing harmony and when I got the
Final Mix back I was like this is this
is what it was supposed to be the entire
time so it's so beautiful it surely was
like a a thing that just kind of
happened yeah and uh we were all just
kind of buckling our seat belts for it
so I loved it
Gentry music scene that you operate with
man I feel like I've been saying Bruno
Mars for years
um we need to make this happen yeah we
need to make that happen but yeah I mean
yeah I mean I I'm a huge fan of of Bruno
I'm a huge fan of I've gotten to write
you know a couple times with Ed Sheeran
I think Ed Sheeran will be super fun to
collab with but they they all happen
when they're supposed to yeah you know
what I mean like those those are the
kind of things that if you force it will
never work but if it just kind of we're
kind of in the same town we're kind of
writing a song it's like let's just
let's do it yeah so are you the George
Clooney of country music now that you
have your own tequila line I just like
that because my hair is starting to turn
I do love the hair right now we're
getting there now you've been
distinguished that's a distinguished
look thank you very much makes me feel
mature I appreciate that
um the George Clooney of what did you
say country music now that you have your
own tequila line hey I've never been
referenced in the same line as George so
thank you I just want to shake your hand
for that no problem don't tell my wife
that you said that yeah uh I guess yeah
I don't know yeah I mean I uh it's kind
of become a thing you know for
celebrities to make liquor products
right and me and my cousin Jeff my
cousin Jeff lives down in Valdosta
Georgia and runs a big pecan operation
and we literally
we did not start this for it to be big
like we we literally were on a ski run
one day and we're like we should start a
tequila company like one of those like
drank too much last night kind of
conversations you know what I'm saying
and uh we literally started tasting a
bunch of Tequilas and got you know
involved with some Distributors and got
to meet a bunch of amazing families down
in Jalisco who owned a bunch of farms
with a bunch of agave and one thing led
to another the next thing you know we uh
we had Dos Primos which means Two
Cousins in Spanish and and uh it got way
cooler than we ever imagined so it for
us it was a passion project that turned
into something really cool something
that we wanted to drink so and why
tequila is that something you've always
loved you know no to be honest really uh
yeah I mean I've had some pretty rough
goes with tequila early early on in my I
feel like we all have those things in my
early 20s but but my wife has always
loved tequila always yeah I mean every
time we go out 21 22 years old she's
like let's do tequila shot I'm like no
like just give me something normal
that's not gonna you know wreck me or
whatever and and as I started to taste
what real tequila tastes like and as I
started to taste you know more higher in
Tequilas I was like dang this sips like
bourbon and I'm a big bourbon guy and so
we spent you know 2 two and a half three
years making sure that our bourbon was
or sorry that our tequila was sippable
you know what I mean like even when you
smell it it's like my mom is like she
drinks box wine like that's that's it
that's her thing I love her and I was
like we just try my tequila and she was
like yes so she tried it and she was
like
I didn't gag you know what I mean like I
was like let's go yes we had something
smooth
um but yeah I mean that's I drink our
tequila the way that I would drink
bourbon in the stone a lot so or I'll
make an old-fashioned with it um
obviously Margarita is great but I'm
kind of more of a neat or On the Rocks
kind of person so okay so I'm gonna
throw some names out with celebrities
who own
tequila
that you think is the light
the light hold their own okay okay
Dwayne The Rock Johnson well at him
doesn't have you don't have to say any
other names George Clooney uh Kendall
Jenner and you out of the four of
four who own their own tequila who do
you think is lightweight
me
yeah no hesitation no hesitation yeah
I've never I've never been a good I've
never been good at going too far okay
can Lauren handle it better than me 100
all right Lauren did you see my wife
shotgun a beer it's like a very
incredible sight like intimidating yes
all right yeah yes Lauren okay and who
do you think can hold their own the best
The Rock The Rock have you seen his like
Instagram and stuff just like and yeah
he's huge no I know I would imagine he
could handle it pretty good he's like a
work of art is that too much is that you
say that yeah I sent it I said it for
both of us uh well listen
congratulations I know you've got you
know your other tour coming up after
this you're just so exciting you're just
killing it right now you're killing it
you're killing it come on